so you guys know i love this gen saki
this is a woman who's just
her ability to lie it's like you gotta
kind of admire it
it's like wow you say a lot of nothing
and when you do
rarely say something it's a lie and she
mumbles and stammers through almost
everything she says
and now she's basically admitting that
the united states is going to go all in
on critical race theory because of
systemic racism
here's sucky delegates the national
education association they approved a
measure last week calling for support of
quote implementation of culturally
responsive education
critical race theory and ethnic studies
curriculum in pre-k
through 12 and higher education
president is obviously a big fan of
education
personally he is a teacher she's a union
teacher i'm wondering
what are the president's thoughts on
anti-racism curriculum
in the classroom well the president
believes that in our history
there are many dark moments and there is
not just
slavery and racism in our history their
systemic racism
that is still impacting society today
and he believes as i believe
as a parent of children that kids should
learn about our history uh so as a
the spouse of an educator and as
somebody who is continues to believe
that children should learn uh not just
the good but also the challenging in our
history and that's part of what we're
talking about here even as it's become
politically
charged okay jen you're lying as usual
here we go let me unpack it so first off
nobody's saying we can't teach the dark
moments
literally nobody is saying it i have not
heard one person
that has any credibility anywhere saying
that we can't teach about the dark
moments of our history that we're not
allowed to teach
about slavery that we're not allowed to
teach about japanese internment
or any other negative thing that the
united states
has done given give an honest assessment
of our founding
no one's saying it well you guys are
saying it but nobody else is arguing
that these things should not be taught
and i'm going to go out on a limb here
and guess that all of you watching this
right now
if you went to school in america whether
you went to private school or public
school you learned a little something
about slavery you learned a little
something about the civil war the
revolutionary war you learned a little
something about our history
and it didn't just say oh america is
fantastic there was no such thing as
slavery
everybody's got a great note and it's
always been that way right like this is
just
absolute uh nonsense then she says kids
should learn about our history
yes so we all agree with that no one's
saying that you can't teach the dark
moments and everyone's saying you should
learn about history but what she's
saying is yes we are going to
usher in critical race theory and teach
everyone about systemic racism now for
the billionth time i know they love to
play semantic games
but systemic racism meaning if there was
racism in the system if there were laws
that
favored one race over another that would
be systemic racism and i would be
completely against it okay
if you said oh if you're black you get
this and you're white you get this
we got a systemically racist problem and
we got to get rid of it
in the times in america where there have
been things like that so like jim crow
laws
we have gotten rid of those things we
fought a civil war to get rid of them
etc etc and in more modern times
you know in the 80s in new york city
there were laws that i think you could
argue were systemically racist
for example if you were arrested for
smoking crack
which generally was happening in the
inner city by black people
the penalties were higher than say if
you were arrested
for snorting cocaine which was happening
down on wall street mostly with white
people
and there was a disparity in what was
going on in terms of the sentencing
we got rid of that okay so absolutely we
can
we can acknowledge that there have been
laws that have been misguided and all of
that stuff and by the way if you brought
cases
forward where there were still people in
jail for x while someone else was in
jail for why
when it should have been similar
sentencing and they weren't we could
talk about that oh and there was a guy
an orange guy what was the orange guy's
name again trump
there was this guy this orange man named
trump you may remember him he's not on
social media anymore
he was trying to do all of this stuff
right he was trying to do this all
with prison reform and he was actually
doing it despite
the best efforts and he was getting the
best efforts of the democrats
and he was getting low-level often
marijuana offenders who were
disproportionately black
be taken out of jail that's what he was
doing but okay i know we don't want to
talk about that
but in essence you're saying okay
systemic racism
is real now this is not a phrase that
joe biden ever said
in his first 47 years of being in public
office that that's a little odd he
just completely forgot to say anything
about it and then
joe biden was also vice president under
a black
president uh barack obama
right right and uh didn't do anything
about systemic racism apparently but now
it's 78 years old
and potentially with dementia oh and by
the way uh i'm not going to say that joe
biden's dementia anymore because you
know i've said it i can't
fully diagnose him with dementia and my
sister said to me
you know you say he has dementia and i
usually say i'm not diagnosing it but
it's like you know it's
sort of like an amorphous term like
something ain't right with this guy so
i'm gonna say for now on that joe biden
has ops
this is old person syndrome i think that
would be a better way of describing
what's going on
with joe biden he has o-p-s o person
syndrome so he forgot
to tell barack obama about the systemic
racism
you know that he was dealing with in
those 47 years uh
and then barack you know barack forgot
to do anything about it himself
and here we are so these people are
absolutely
ridiculous but if you think that this
thing isn't all tied together and how
the unions are involved in everything
else you may remember on friday
we played this video of randy weingarten
who's the president
of the largest teachers union and if you
want to listen to somebody speaking out
of both sides of their mouth
i present you randy weingarten
critical race theory is
not taught in elementary schools
or middle schools or high schools
it's a method of examination taught
in law school and in college
that helps analyze whether systemic
racism exists and in particular
whether it has an effect on law and
public
policy
but cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history
okay so this woman i mean this is sake
level lying so on one hand she's saying
it's not being taught now we know
it is being taught right we've given you
plenty of examples here
but just in the last couple days chris
ruffo i mentioned him on the show weekly
at this point
who's doing the greatest work when it
comes to exposing this nonsense
he found a list of 30 school districts
in america that
are teaching it right now by their own
doctrines right by their own documents
that they used to teach
at least 30 school districts that are
now teaching this stuff
in k through 12. so on one hand she's
saying it's not being taught and then if
you listen to the last sentence there
she's saying but
you know it is an honest assessment of
what's going on in the world and it's an
honest assessment of our history
well if that's what you believe lady
then why wouldn't you be teaching it
so everything that these people say is
just
complete nonsense and as i often say
we've got our work
cut out for us
foreign